All right.
Let's see what is continuing to be on people's
minds on the phones at six one, seven, eight,
three zero 47 50.
So folks holding on.
Let's go.
Let's go to Deon.
We haven't heard from Dion in the four one,
seven, uh, for, um, several months.
Uh, actually close to a year.
Deon, what's going on?
Hi.
How's it going?
Yeah, I haven't called in in quite awhile.
I had a like, I don't know if it's a question
as much as a statement that I think we mischaracterize
things with the left and right dichotomy too
much.
When it's more of a, it's like informed, misinformed
and disinfect.
Yes.
Sometimes that is the case.
Sometimes that's the case, but I think there's,
there's other, some, so sometimes we mischaracterize
positions as left.
Right.
When really it's the fact based position and
the one that's not, sometimes we miss characterizing
because the is really one about, you know,
for example, corruption versus anticorruption.
But listen, Dionne, it sounds crazy where
you are.
So I don't know if you had a specific part
I could answer offline but I can barely hear
you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm on a wired headphone.
Is this a better connection?
You know, it's not a connection.
It just sounds like chaos in the background.
I don't know if you're at a daycare or something
like that.
Oh no, I'm not.
Okay.
Well, I apologize.
I'll let you go.
Okay.
All right, Dan, great to hear from you.
I appreciate it.
You are completely right.
Sometimes it's not about left versus right.
Sometimes it's about do you know the facts
or don't you?
And I love it.
I appreciate that Dionne called in and made
that very important point.